i have 100 random minecraft players here
and they don't know this but lava is
slowly gonna rise until it covers the
whole map and here's the cool part they
have no idea what's going on and to make
things even more confusing the second to
last person to die wins a 10 000 subway
gift card not the last person the second
to last server free the players
ouch let's go baby the 100 players are
now free server begin the lava climbing
all is normal in the minecraft world
they're just collecting blocks just
doing their thing are we working
together a little bit oh yeah little
carl chandler action yeah we should get
away from everybody dude we need a water
bucket i know we need blocks mine blocks
chris
this is dropping creepers on me
everyone's just doing their own thing
collecting materials little do they know
in three minutes lava is slowly gonna
start rising until it kills them all
that sounded kind of morbid i wonder
what their voice chat is talking about i
suck i haven't played minecraft in like
six months i need iron i'm gonna steal
this kid's iron i just stole the kids
iron out of his furnace did you actually
yeah dude pvp is not on now's the
perfect time try to get more yo you want
a diamond pick have a diamond pick chris
look i threw a diamond picked him and he
has a nose oh here we'll add a sword
maybe you'll notice it now nope
all right well i guess you don't want it
sir we'll just pick it all back up hey
whenever you watch this video leave a
comment about how sad you are or i'm
gonna go mining i'm mining what are you
mining for iron oh jimmy look there's a
wolf up here he got still yeah i know i
already hit him you gotta hit him too
i'm gonna help him get down there you go
wolf have fun oh wait now he's gonna get
hit by the lava no he was safe
oh wait it bans you when you die well i
didn't know that i didn't know that i
didn't know that could someone unban me
let's see where carl is i bet he's
stockpiling resources how did you know
it
what the this
chris
i killed him no you didn't i couldn't
even run away chris always killing you
all right i feel like they've had enough
time to get materials wouldn't you say i
think so server turn on pvp and also
while you're at it servers start the
lava climbing let's get some action oh
oh this person found the chest at the
top of the mountain oh did you place a
super op chest at the top of the
mountain and now that guy's gonna win
yep okay chandler's sky blocking get
away they can't stop me no you get away
chris look at this nerd sky blocking
notice how everyone else is down there
on the ground and he's building up it's
almost like he has insider information
that's helping him wait chris is giving
me more blocks yeah
they don't want to kill me oh i'm
starting to see lava on the ground oh
that was me oh i was trying to kill
chandler i'm literally building straight
up all right i'm at the height limit you
built straight up you're out of
materials at the height limit we on top
of the world i'm putting creepers
everywhere to make it spicy yeah let me
test it
oh yep pvp's on hey jimmy while you're
looking at the lava i'll be looking at
this lava actually that's an alpaca
let's see how deep the lava is right now
oh all right so the lava is about this
deep it's about that deep about that
deep these guys are friends you know how
you break away a friendship diamond
sword in between them fight for it kill
your friend oh oh you betrayed his
friend for the diamond sword
oh there it is you have an iron sword
yeah
who gave that dude diamond armor and a
diamond sword did you die yes he got all
on his own yeah sure sure he did i'm
switching to spectator mode let's see
what the law is this is cool look at all
these innocent players just chilling in
their mine shafts oh boy hold on this
guy's about to get killed by lava oh my
gosh shoot me look look look look look
oh no he had no idea like we said before
none of them know what the challenge is
they have no idea that lava is rising
only the biggest of the massivest of the
biggest brains will figure it out and
survive oh a fight's breaking out over
here guys guys stop burning piece it
together gentlemen oh it's already
surface level now i bet voice chat is
freaking out probably screaming right
now why are my fingers sweating lots of
people are still on the floor what are
they gonna do start building guys stop
fighting and start building hello
what are you up to just playing some sky
block man
we can't get back into the server so i'm
gonna join chandler and some sky block
chris 58 people have died so far it
looks like a lot of people are starting
to get the memo and pillaring up
actually i take it back two people just
died chris yeah you're alpaca go go go
come on alpaca i'll pack up my bags and
get you out of here come on wait if i
get a lead can i fly with him oh
i can show you the world
jimmy look i saved him oh my god forget
about your alpaca a fight's breaking out
you're back and join the fight get him
alpaca oh no he's bloodthirsty
hit my alpaca this guy doesn't even have
armor what is he doing chris on a scale
one to ten how mean would it be if i did
this
all right i did it
you just killed that man right in front
of my pack and what am i supposed to
tell him oh wait ah too close to the
lava with my alpaca 32 remain three more
just died here watch this i'll just
scare him watch he's gonna be really
scared
no why did you jump in the lava it was a
joke no
my authentic enough
why does everything i love done chris
just leave the game slash band
you can't ban yourself yeah oh my gosh
this is height limit eight people are at
world height only one will win and don't
forget it's not the last person to
survive that wins it's the second to
last person that wins the coveted
ten thousand dollar subway gift card
first the fight's about to happen right
here fight fight this will make him
fight
oh
oh oh oh oh
oh no
salute
she took the honorable way out chris
there are some people who haven't even
started building up yet i'm gonna put
cats on people's bases all right oh my
gosh i just saw one of the cats fall
tell me this kid isn't sweat yeah he's
sweaty i think he needs a couple of cats
you better not kill the cats or i'll be
sad i want these two right here to fight
they're looking at each other in the
eyes fight or make love up to you oh
oh he's going forward oh
oh that was incredible i want anarchy
i'm connecting him cats are going the
cats understand look at this little
kitten it's like let me hit him i'll
kill him
the kid's engaging in combat yo someone
just fell oh he fell in the water hey
look at his head look at him shaking his
head you can do this he he's like
begging us to help him you got this
golden
goldengamer4269
bill
build
oh oh that's his only block no
chris oh it was his fault for only
having one block battle about to ensue i
hope they realize the stakes on the line
and by stakes on the line i mean the two
thousand five dollar foot longs they
could buy with lots of steak on them six
years of five dollar foot longs every
single day what were you doing six years
ago uh being a dumb child now imagine if
between dumb child and still dumb child
you ate a five dollar foot long every
day for free i'd probably be a fat dumb
child dude you you were right about red
he is a sweaty kid big fights big fights
red guy sweating oh oh oh oh red guy
right guys stay here guys running no
red guy got beat fight fight fight
no fight we're just making him really op
you know that right fight fight this has
got to start a fight right here
oh there we go
all right no go back
oh no no
[Music]
yo if you're watching this i'm sorry for
taking the ten thousand dollar subway
gift card away from you no footlongs for
that kid we have a glitch and chandler
and carl can't rejoin on their computer
so they're just going to join here stop
the lava from rising pause it here 13
players remain people that are building
with water about their regretted yeah
seriously 13 players 2 000 5 foot long
what will happen and instead of the lava
rising let's have the border start to
shrink and like with the lava we're
telling them nothing dude this dude's
chilling on a furnace he's building with
furnaces right now oh fight oh oh oh oh
oh oh
[Music]
i love how this dude's just like yeah
i'm not gonna do anything
carl see the border oh god it is slowly
closing in creep in ten people remain
ten people remain the border is
shrinking ten thousand dollars on the
line what will happen i think you mean
two thousand five dollar subway foot
long sorry i misspoken deaths you are
correct that is exactly what i meant the
war is breaking out oh box cops oh that
other guy if he comes in to help that's
it for the diamond yeah and he will and
he will oh
clean double kill we're speeding this up
border is shrinking server rise to lava
again let's hit her from all angles
raise the lava shrink the borders made
the smartest brain win and remember it's
the second to last person that gets the
10 000 subway gift card oh this kid's
about to get lava right beside him four
people remain oh my gosh use your
shields you nimrods no what are you
doing
more like geo lava
oh tricks
[Music]
wait who's gonna die the lava just went
to the top instantly yeah the lava rose
up and altryx was the second to dive it
came down to the wire through the wire
altryx yes yes you were not the last to
die you were the second to last to die
no no
don't don't say no because this
challenge is actually different the
second to last person is the winner of
this challenge so you're technically the
winner congratulations no
congratulations
on your 10 000
subway gift card
i have no words i really don't have no
words those sound like words what is
your typical five dollar foot long
chicken and cheese that's a lot of
chickens